[Musique]
on va passer à l'hyper view vous allez
voir première fois c'est un peu de
terribles comme salle hyper view moment
on s'y fait très bien donc après on a eu
dans cette émission adriana karembeu on
a eu laeticia casta
mais là-bas c'est l'hyper moussa et donc
après la fin c'est tout noir mais tout
s'apprend
je viens donc après avoir eu la plus
jolie fille du monde on s'est dit qu'on
allait inviter la richesse normale à
puma de la plus drôle parce que non
seulement vous êtes jolie mais en plus
on roule à vous appeler mathilde cini
faut le dire aux gens ce que tout le
monde ne vous connais pas bien sur la
meme voilà donc vous êtes à soeur
d'emmanuelle seigner
ouais déjà plus fins et plus connu que
vous et surtout elle a épousé romane
polonsky la croix de soeur emmanuelle
et quand quand votre soeur s'est pas
commencer à vivre avec romane polanski
ça vous a inquiété ou non moi parce
qu'il avait quand même une drôle de
réputation en polanski quand il est
arrivé en france ça vous a pas inquiété
d'une heure ou plus du tout pas du tout
moi vous êtes la petite fille de louis
seigner
enfin je sais pas si c'est à dire à
grand-chose à grand monde enfin toyal la
comédie française n'est pas sûr
peut-être pas les jeunes mais quand même
oui vous remercie je ferai pas ce que je
voulais
c'est un peu je vous admire d'anglo
enseigne évidemment les vieux cadres
utile et moi je collais ma génération
c'est à jacques tati l'invité dans un
dîner envie de fait semblant donc vous
êtes né le 7 janvier on dit ça ça
intéresse absolument personne je sais
bien mais ça matin 10h une île 6 7
janvier oui 7 à 10 mg moins drôle alors
vous avez dit moi si jamais un jour ou
si celle ci connaît celle affectant
moriké maman tina maze et après on pour
l'arrêt dans sa valise il s'est fait
monter les faits oui je pensais qu'ils
allaient sortir et hambourg la reine qui
joue la semaine prochaine alors baptisé
le voleur l'a vite moi donc à partir de
mercredi on vous voit dans vénus beauté
institut film de tonie marshall avec
nathalie baye bulle ogier
le bihan robert hossein claire nebout et
c1
quand vous jouez le rôle d'une petite
esthéticienne samantha oui c'est tout
c'est tout un plein de femmes dans un
institut de beauté c'est très bien moi
j'ai vu très jolie fille a bien fait les
progrès ciani marchal parce que j'avais
vu que tinto avec est en germe d'un cône
du talent oui elle a fait des progrès on
avait déjà fait un très bon film agora
n'est pas audrey j'en sais rien en face
c'est un film qui est très très abouti
les machines près donc film serait allé
la maman de thomas emmanuelle riva
révélé que des gens mais c'est un très
beau film très émouvant et qui regardera
la bande annonce à la fin on va vous
voir au mois de mars dans un film
quant à suivre on l'a pas vue pour le
moment s'appelle belle-maman film deux
avions c'est avec aguillon avec
catherine deneuve
c'est ce qu'a fait [ __ ] douce et saint
gabriel aghion c'est pour ce film que
vous avez perdu 8 kg ouais et dans le
film l'aveu dans l'autre en fait en fait
vous explique l'hyper view devinez
combien d'erreurs se glisse dans les
questions de thierry ardisson
oui j'ai perdu 8 on m'a demandé
oui on m'a dit enfin m'a dit ça il faut
du week-end on met en avant le rôle moi
il faut que tu maigri un peu voilé dans
le tony marsh justement ça se joue les
dents le tonie marshall jette bien mais
c'est bien mais également alors donc les
débits qu'ils aient perdu avant le 24
octobre après le 24 octobre et pour la
déclaration pourquoi l'eire 3 vous étiez
en train de les perdre 24 octobre
c'était quoi le 24 on va voir ce que
c'était le 24 octobre magnéto
je sens bien que j'ai un problème
c'est que je t'aime ou si ces eaux-là
est ce toujours les mêmes c'est nous qui
changeront
les jours
dit j'ai un problème j'ai bien peur que
je t'aimerai j'ai un problème
j'en ai bien peut aussi en perdre on y
gagne quand même
voilà donc ça c'était le 24 octobre
c'était chaud le show sylvie vartan qui
a été produit et réalisé par jérôme
grosjean avec stéphane gâteau et c'est
là bas voilà c'est là vous avez
rencontré laurent gerra se faisait pas
trop en parler tout à l'heure parce que
je voulais qu'on vous voit ensemble et
ça s'est passé comment là vous êtes
obligé de me raconter je suis une
curiosité
elle est passionnée bien présent le
connaissez lyon leader
voilà ce que c'est tournez manège
maintenant alors comment ça a été c'est
un coup de foudre
ah ouais sur la chanson ouais pendant la
chanson hard way ya des textes un peu
débile mais non il fallait un problème
je crois bien que je t'aime et tout et
c'est vrai et on s'est aimés sur cette
chanson non mais c'est vrai ça fait
super sympa mais bon ça vous écoute vous
et en histoire la raison c'est justement
mais c'est vrai c'est honnête c'est vrai
on s'est aimés sur cette chanson et vous
inviter à dîner après enfin je sais pas
si il m'a invité mais on s'est téléphoné
et puis c'est gênant mais après il m'a
invité au monde à dîner
on vous a fait rire les a fait rire mais
ça a marché parce que j'aime j'ai vu des
images interviews de vous ou vous disiez
moi si un jour je rencontre un mec qui
me fait marrer il aura gagné donc c'est
lui non mais c'est nazi on n'a plus
d'espoir non mais c'est tout le reste
sont pas en voudrait il fait rire
évidemment mais c'est tout c'est tout le
reste c'est quoi tout le bas à
l'intelligence tout ça sert à quoi
non mais c'est pas vous êtes plutôt
intervient en amont florange à les âmes
au dessus de 30 ans donc vous avez vos
choix
j'ai lu ça aussi je les aime plus âgées
aux essais requin un homme de mon âge
qui à 31 ans je le trouve vraiment là
c'est pas possible quoi on va voir on va
voir encore un petit bout de laurent
gerra parce que nous aussi on vous en
prie 6
[Musique]
e
il y en a marre d'entendre ces trois
coups sûrs qu'ils surveillent
ge
[Musique]
on nous laisse une
esmeralda
[Musique]
ça nous
l'heureux cause
[Musique]
il dit
sauter
ça vous
[Musique]
ce
ces trois crétins peuvent se nomme
être sous le bras
ce fait pour
est-ce me
ouais
il a réalisé il a réalisé un véritable
exploit parce que je passerais bien
regarder les images ya catherine
trautmann qui grille où elle est assez
osé parce que comme c'est le succès oui
toujours les choses un peu et vous tirez
sur les vaches sacrées pas sur les
ambulances
c'est toujours plus risqué de d'attaqué
quelque chose qui est un succès et tout
ça vous vous étiez déjà très fan de
johnny hallyday dont qui vous a sûrement
séduit en imitant johnny hallyday 1 ok
vous le fait que pour vous à oui mais
quand vous êtes tous les deux au beau
oui mais que vous avez un nom mais bien
sûr quand même un truc que je comprends
pas chez vous c'est vous dit quand je
vois sardou je manque m'évanouir
c'est physique ça m'a bien dit ça vous
bat dans un journal je vais pas inventer
des trucs pareils oui c'est fini
maintenant c'est dur pour les buts n'a
annoncé maintenant mais j'aime beaucoup
sardou kablan michel non mais c'est vrai
alors ouais c'est vrai moi j'ai toujours
adoré non m non mais j'explique parce
que quand on quand on peut croire que
c'est les gens me disent oui m'enfin les
les réacs droite pas quoi moi je m'en
fous les artistes leur leur opinion
réalité je m'en contrefous je trouve que
d'abord ils n'ont pas affiché enfin on
n'a pas à savoir - michel sardou
quantique anti chien trouve qu'il a une
belle voix il me gêne il me plaisait
physiquement maintenant j'en wind amène
à si vous avez une chose qui est très
rare de nos jours où tout le monde pense
à peu près la même chose nous dit penser
la même chose à une chose qui est très
rare c'est que vous dites peut-être
parce que vous n'êtes pas encore assez
dans le showbiz peut-être parce que vous
êtes vraiment différente
vous dites que vous pensez si un peu
quand par exemple vous sortez un film
superbe vive la république et vous dit à
ce moment là que vous préférez chirac à
jose par eric rochant le réalisateur
vous insulte en vous disant m'enfin on
dit pas ça dans le show business tout le
monde est de gauche
dictée de gauche sinon tu réussiras
jamais et vous vous continuez à le dire
ce que je suis pas hypocrite
c'est bien simple c'est que c'est rare
ça alors
non mais moi j'ai moi je m'en fiche avec
grand père il était gaulliste
on peut être bien être de droite ont
peut être bien de gauche a fait dire ça
veut rien dire je lis et ravissent tous
la même chose par exemple quand vous
dites que vous aimez pas le rap que vous
n'avez pas à détester ntm par exemple
louis basse elle est hôtesse de l'air
non mais c'est vrai noté m ou dit l'ex-n
du pognon en crachant sa société ça vous
énerve ça ntm chadouli m franchie ouais
mais font chier il me faut c'est parce
qu'ils sont à la télé ils ont fumé 50p
tard ils sont moches
ils sont sales et ils sont là vas-y
chant q la société [ __ ] ma vie et ça
ça m'intéresse pas mais il faut quand
même la société achète quand même si
leur dise quoi contrairement aux dragées
fuca commencer par la sécurité sociale
alors est ce que en plus alors
maintenant vous vous êtes en train de
tourner un nouveau film avec cette année
c'est bien ah mais non mais attendez non
mais attendez moi je vais vous dire un
truc votre attaché lundi matin bien la
spatm attaché de presse va peut-être
vous engueuler c'est sûr parce que l'on
attendait mais on discute de 10pts amer
mais les gens les gens qui regardent la
télé je peux vous dire que les gens qui
regardent la télé sont peu habitués à
autant de franchise de ça c'est bien
parce que nous ici on est toutefois
qu'il faut bien dire que toutes les
conneries qu'on dit on en pense pas vous
êtes jalouses des stars du porno qui ont
des grosses bouche des gros seins faux
pas du tout non pas du tout s'est tu
m'aimes
je suis même fasciné qu'on dépense
autant d'argent et autant d'énergie pour
être encore plus moche et aussi moche
quoi
la déprime il ya des fous qui sont
ravissantes monsieur était ravissante
comme d'ailleurs laetitia casta c'est
vachement bien ce qu elle a dit j'ai
entendu dans l'émission elle a dit non
moi je veux pas refaire parce que
j'attends oui on verra dans 20 ans à 20
ans il faut refaire des trucs c'est
grand mais à 21 m elles le font à 15 ans
c'est vrai mais bien celui où l'on
achète un miroir qui va venir
bonsoir vous connaissez tous le monde
patricia gagnon dans le pied mathilde
seigner stéphane bern
[Musique]
alors en fait on vous a invité parce que
il va être beaucoup de questions que
vous à mon avis d'ici l'été
mais aussi pour une autre raison et s'il
a absolument pour une autre raison c'est
que vous avez dit que laurent gerra
était rigolo et intelligent alors là
évidemment comme vous avez la fiancée de
laurent gerra devant vous effectivement
vous êtes déjà de très copains alors
jack lang
vous avez une forme éblouissante ouais
c'est vrai il a dit ça vous avez une
forme une forme éblouissante on peut
dire votre âge non bah oui bien sûr
soixante ans par donc pas tout à fait
praticable aujourd'hui suis pas mon âge
mais alors alors vous avez un secret
quand même c'est que vous dit on à
genoux pour embrasser bon mais pas en
âge mais effectivement vous avez un
secret c'est vous dit en fait nos sports
comme churchill sûr vous ne faites pas
de sport c'est le secret de votre fort
je me balade un peu quelques quelques
itinéraires à pied ouais un peu de ski
de temps à autre et voila voila mais
vous n'êtes pas ruiner la santé en état
c'était bien la santé à faire du jogging
sûrement pas aux normes heures bon mais
c'est bien parfois c'est un truc à
savoir alors vous êtes ministre de la
culture je le fus quand vous dites que
vous l'êtes pas personne ne vous croira
toute façon donc si vous voulez autant
dire que voulez vous êtes président de
la commission des affaires étrangères
c'est pas c'est bien comme job c'est
passionnant j'aime léger mais relâchés
dans l'achat de voyages en tout cas
ouais peut alors que je suis très
casanier alors jaurès à paris beaucoup
en avant vers les lois il ya eu valéry
giscard d'estaing avant vous ne lui et
c'est une autre stature ah bon
lui il avait voyagé déjà beaucoup
est ce que vous regrettez un peu votre
pré candidature de 95
c'est à dire on avance des histoires
anciennes oui là ça va ça fait quatre
ans qu'on soit au courant oui ça vous
regrettait pas de partie des choses qui
vous ont enrichi ce n'est pas leur grève
ouais nous avons regrettez pas d'avoir
des jeux spa est un looser ça a dépassé
ma pensée et il a eu raison de me donner
tort très bien répondu alors vous êtes
maire de blois là je termine le
curriculum vitae vous êtes maire de
blois ce qui vous a valu le surnom de
langue de bois mais j'espère que ce soir
j'espère que c'est pas de moi c'est toi
qui redit ce soir j'espère vous ne serez
pas langue de bois bon on vous accuse
souvent de courir après la modernité
alors aujourd'hui excusez pas le
sentiment d'être un petit peu quand même
sur le plan de la modernité d'être
concurrencé quand même par cohn-bendit
pour qu on n'est jamais assez nombreux
oui sauf que vous n'êtes pas des mêmes
partis aux deux parties nous important
dans la même famille d'accord est ce que
vous savez ce que ça veut dire courir
qu'europe1 spécialistes et des réponses
comme ça sans burqa vous lisez non parce
que j'ai vu que vous lisez les 1 occupe
régis loison tu sais ce que ça veut dire
quoi non du tout bon non c'est courir
c'est alors je voyais maintenant non
mais c'est quand je fais pas attention
lui hier non blancs non non c'est en
fait la tendance
oui non la théorie de cuir c'est de dire
qu'il ya plus seulement les hommes les
femmes et les homosexuels mais qu'en
fait il ya autant de chèques ski adam
vie voilà ces gens c'est le coup
[Applaudissements]
oui bien sûr et cela de répondre à cette
question vraiment en toute franchise
parmi tous les successeurs vous avez eu
à la culture
je vais les rappeler très vite il ya eu
jacques eu tout bon il ya eu philippe
françois léotard par françois léotard
avant il ya eu tout bon
il ya eu 12 blazy maintenant catherine
trautmann qui a été le meilleur à votre
avis il s'améliore au fur et à mesure
est-ce que vous allez être candidat du
ps aux européennes voilà une question
qui ne s'est pas posé à mon petit
cerveau encore vous c'est que ça dessine
vous savez que la décision est la
décision va être prise le 10 février
vous le savez bien donc c'est dans
quinze jours laissez les socialistes
réfléchir oui à cela prend du temps il
faut bien que j'ai soupesé une grève
parce que c'est vrai que je ne trouve
pas une vie simone pas d'eux veut pas de
vous non je ne passais pas qu'il veut
pas il a dit que françois hollande était
un bon candidat
vous pensez que françois va me sera un
bon candidat avec celle d'un candidat
par magna prenne le cumul et l'autre
partie du fromage y avoir de cumul c'est
ça le problème
donc vous savez pas franchement je ne
sais pas moi je trouve alors je peux me
permettre de vous dire ça vous feriez un
excellent quand je ne sais pas est en
tout cas françois hollande jusqu'à la
10e très bon candidat c'est un très bon
gardien il faut le choisir
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas victime
finalement d'une sorte de des mitterrand
10 à sion lionel jospin cherche à faire
oublier les années mitterrand mitterrand
n'aurait prévu à qui vous seriez pas au
gouvernement il avait dit on va
abandonner superphénix l'armée jack lang
c'est vrai que vous avez pas renier
mitterrand est pourtant il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses qui sont sortis
depuis quelques années je vais pas vous
les listes et parce que tout le monde
les a en tête
bon vous malgré tout et c'est honorable
pas ça veut dire vous êtes fidèles
malgré tout vous continuez à défendre la
mémoire du président mitterrand
plus que jamais et vous avez même créé à
blois un pont françois-mitterrand oui
bon est ce que finalement c'est passé à
votre problème est ce que est ce que
finalement on pourrait pas parce que des
gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
gouvernement pourrait pas vous reprocher
cette fidélité alors que veulent faire
oublier ces années mitterrand je pense
pas que soient leurs problèmes
d'ailleurs si vous parlez de mes amis au
gouvernement en tout cas personnellement
je ne changerait pas d'un iota la la
fidélité à une personne que j'ai
respecté que je respecte et que j'aimais
je la maintiens plus forte que jamais
dire que c'est une question aussi te
dirait de d'éthique de vie ouais même
pas beaucoup ce mot mais je considère
que la fidélité à quelques idées ou à
quelques personnes avec qui on a partagé
des moments heureux ou malheureux fait
la noblesse de la vie si on si tout cela
est cassée qu'est ce qui reste de ta vie
et dumas vous êtes fidèle à dumas aussi
à roland dumas tous voulaient absolument
faire une galerie de portage portrait
vous vous êtes le seul aujourd'hui qui
dit enfin des rares qui dit dumas doit
pas démissionner j'ai trop loin expliqué
à 16h06 comme amazon il est minuit à
quelle heure est-il on nous aurait mis
minuit je me défile pas non mais comment
soit christine deviers-joncour après ça
aurait été sympa de savoir si vous étiez
fidèles vous à dumas parce que lui il
est plus tellement fidèle elle enfin bon
c'est pas grave
voulez-vous qu'on en parle c'est
paniquer c'est une question de fidélité
dans ce cas précis c'est une question de
principe par rapport à l'idée que je me
fais de la séparation des pouvoirs
il ya des juges d'un côté et elle est
juge de l'autre j'estime que tant qu une
personne connue ou inconnue n'a pas été
mise en cause de façon trouver certaines
il doit être considéré on l'a proclamé
il ya deux siècles que l'innocent et ça
vaut en particulier pour les gens qu'on
ne connaît pas qui tous les jours encore
malheureusement trop souvent sont
victimes d'arbitraire multiples de
l'administration ou de ou d'abus
policiers ou ou judiciaire à travers
vous est expliqué on est sympa prix ça
m'a pris une heure et c'est clair mais
personne n'a dormi pia pas de mauvais
endroit pour s'expliquer croyant
peut-être derrière ça aurait été mieux
bon alors on va on recommence on
continue sur vos idées politiques qui
nous concerne nous les jeunes
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya alors alors le
cannabis vas-y rangé dans un sac
le cannabis 30,6 en tandem
vous êtes partisans de la légalisation
de la dépénalisation je suis partisan
qu'on change la loi à genève comment je
ne sais pas au juste lui dire voilà qu'
il n'y a aucune raison de désigner une
le cannabis comme le la messe le seul
système de d'un de drogue qu'ils soient
pénalisés à ce point pourquoi pas
l'alcool pourquoi pas la cigarette
pourquoi pas d'autres choses
voilà j'estime que j'ai dit jack lang
vous pouvez sortir le plus tard il est
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
et bien tout le monde
cette bourde la légalisation lui non
mais moi c'est moi je n'ai jamais fumé
des joints de ma vie parce que j'ai pas
entendu que la vérité c'est ça qu'on
veut savoir c'est rare non mais je suis
honnête j'ai jamais fumé des joints par
contre suis d'accord parce qu'en fait ça
change rien c'est vrai que c'est pas
plus grave qu autre chose et que le fait
d'interdire ces idiots ça change rien
qu'on moi je ne suis pas pour que les
gens fument des joints mais je m'en
fiche quoi je comprends vous attendez
avec laurent gerra mois n'a peu réac
lors non il est sain sinon arrivé un peu
réac laurent c'est pas une insulte à
gérer axa veut rien dire en face ça veut
dire aux réagir à des shows et vous a
déjà emmené chez ses parents à
bourg-en-bresse
ouais d'accord c'est bien passé très
bien bonsoir
après simon shaw en cuir ni perdu où
vous allez voir c'est non mais c'est
rien du tout en fait c'est aussi la
bonne invité parce que c'est sûrement la
bonne invité et je suis pas tellement
gay on a lu cette semaine dont vous fait
revivre ça vous arrive et avec le
sourire
déjà on a lu cette semaine
l'article du parisien on a en vous a
entendu sur rtl vous a entendu sur
europe et donc on a eu envie de vous
avoir est de vous poser toutes les
questions qui se posent à votre sujet
voilà alors tout à l'heure en vous
présentant moi j'ai dit christine
deviers-joncour mon camarade ruquier qui
n'en rate pas une a dit la [ __ ] de la
république ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est que c'est le titre du temps mais
c'est les petits gars de mon livre c'est
le titre du livre enfin c'est un cetain
un surnom qui vous a été donné c'est pas
vous qui voulez oui j'entends beaucoup
de gens dire que je me suis baptisée
comme ça en fait non je crois que si on
lit la quatrième de couverture on
comprend vite gré que si je ne suis pas
baptisé comme ça j'ai écrit ce livre
pour montrer que je ne suis pas là
walton la république on a baptisé comme
ça et je lui ai appris en sortant voilà
si je la fais parce que il croisait
accepter que le livre porte ce titre
aussi mais parce que je crois que c'est
tous les courages et que je crois que je
voulais justement montré que c'était
tellement trop comme ça qu'à travers ce
que j'ai écrit je voulais prouver que
j'étais pas cette femme voilà alors
roland dumas vous appeler ma petite
matar et on pourrait aussi vous appelez
la mata hari du périgord et ouais mais
c'est plus sympa la matawinie
moi j'avoue que ça m'a fait drôle parce
qu'au départ thierry ardisson m'a dit
tiens tu il faut absolument que tu lises
le bouquin de dumas j'ai cru que
c'étaient les trois mousquetaires et en
fait c'était le comte de monte cristo
[Applaudissements]
alors bon votre histoire ça peut aussi
s'appeler trois hommes et une femme
parce que quand on regarde un peu votre
à votre vie finalement comme quand on
lit ce bouquin donc la [ __ ] la
république chez calmann lévy on pourrait
effectivement appelé ça trois hommes
trois hommes une femme si ce n'est pas
peu dire sans être vous n'êtes pas eu de
chance avec les mecs quoi
non mais c'est vrai vous avez comment
vous êtes fille unique de deux
instituteurs à 10 ans je raconte votre
vie comme ça vous m'arrêtez mais je veux
pas être londres à 17 ans vous préparer
le baccalauréat au lycée la boétie à
sarlat et puis dans la même ville il ya
un garçon qui s'appelle jean jacques de
peretti qui depuis a fait une très belle
carrière a quitté ministre de monsieur
juppé et lui ses parents sont au maroc
ils l'ont envoyée à sarlat il est très
ambitieux il vous dit un jour je serai
maire de sarlat il ce qui est arrivé
mais voilà il monte cyrano et c'est
hélas drame alors maintenant je sais que
ça pour les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ça
paraît absolument incroyable enfin on a
le même âge donc nous on a connu cette
époque c'est vrai que quand une fille se
retrouver enceinte était très difficile
voilà et donc vous êtes retrouvée
enceinte mais je le regrette aujourd'hui
j'ai un fils nervis frédéric que très
très beau absolument et donc bah voilà
vous êtes mariés vous êtes mariés alors
que peut-être qu'aujourd'hui les moeurs
ayant évolué vous seriez fait avorter
oui bah tant mieux finalement dont tu
ravi d'avoir eu sept enfants
voilà donc mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
il était hors de question de c'était la
galère à l'époque c'étaient des
aiguilles à tricoter sur l'étape de
qualifié d' absolument oui c'est moi une
loi que simone veil dont on parlait tout
à l'heure a justement fait voilà alors
donc vous vous mariez avec jean jacques
de peretti parce que vous êtes enceinte
vous avez frédéric et la l'engrenage
commence parce que votre vie c'est un
engrenage
mais ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire dans
ma vie c'est que en fait la politique on
n'en faisait pas chez moi mais mes
parents étaient enseignants on n'a
jamais fait de policiers et que
finalement si on regarde ce parcours qui
est absolument être
c'est vrai que la politique me poursuit
tout le temps les hommes politiques
alors que je les ai pas cherché
ça c'est drôle c'est le destin c'est le
destin c'est comme les rois
il y peut rien
frappe c'est que vous avez un point
commun et camilla parker bowles a fait
que mon dieu mon dieu vous êtes aussi
vous fait l'unanimité contre vous dans
un pays alors que finalement la pauvre
n'y peut rien il est aimé par un homme
qui est connue je suis pas d'accord avec
vous je fais pas l'unanimité contre moi
parce qu'on ne connaît pas j'aimerais
vous dire depuis que j'ai écrit ce livre
je suis très étonné mais je reçois des
lettres de l'acteur et je veux le dire
ce soir je vais en profiter les
remercier qui sont extraordinaires et
qui me donne une force vous pouvez pas
imaginer on voulait vraiment et si moi
je reste et je continue je continue je
vais je continue on aura le temps on
aura le temps après de parler plus à
fond des bois mais je raconte votre vie
parce que quand on connaît pas bozzi
dumas voilà exactement donc vous monter
à paris lui fait sciences po il
travaille un peu dans une agence de
mannequins pour faire du booking vous
fêtez qui faisait ça oui vous fêtez le
défilé de lingerie au salon du
prêt-à-porter etc
des photos et puis finalement bon vous
passez vos nuits chez castel ou fumer
des pétards enfin les pavés tarn
j'aime essayer non non non plus j'aurais
peut-être dû rouge a depuis quelques
mois peut-être que j'aurais dû savourer
des donc votre enfant est envoyé dans le
périgord parce que ni le couple explose
koster que jean jacques de peretti il
est absorbé par son boulot
vous vous êtes absorbé par le cri d'un
enfant quand on fait des études c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile et donc lui
est ce qu'on l'a il est pris par le
démon de la politique qui devient chargé
de missions auprès de messmer à matignon
qui évoquent et électriciens premier
ministre après donc votre fils frédéric
avait des problèmes de santé dont
pouvait pas travailler vous vous
retrouvez comme beaucoup de femmes
effectivement ça parle ça parle aux gens
votre histoire parce que vous retrouvez
avec un baume sur les bras on peut pas
travailler parce qu'il faut s'occuper de
lui là vous rencontrez un dénommé claude
joncour et vous raccrochez un peu à lui
on peut on peut le dire vous lui
demandez de vous épousez je lui demande
pas de m'épouser mais c'est vrai qu'il
est touché un petit peu par par ma
situation et puis tu puisqu'elle
probablement je lui plais bien et puis
moi j'ai vu le moyen d'être épaulé et de
pouvoir garder mon fils auprès de moi
qui étais toujours chez ma mère elle
opte donc de reprendre mon fils vous
marier avec lui alors c'est un peu
compliqué bon parce que
il s'est pas son fils donc le week-end
il le met devant la porte en disant il
faut des gens qui étaient très occupé
puisqu'il commencé à faire ses premiers
pas en politique donc c'est vrai ça
prend du temps alors j'encours claude
gens courent donc votre second mari il
vous présente un jour alfred sirven donc
c'est lui qui une fois ci je dis pas
qu'il a fait l'entremetteur enfin il
était assez content elle c'est d'accord
pour vous rencontriez sirven et que vous
travaillez avec lui il faut dire qu'il
sirven alfred sirven dit nous parce que
c'est le seul dans votre bouquin que
j'ai lu deux fois qui finalement son
sort un peu si c'est vraiment parce que
c'est lui qu'ils ont braqué en tout la
fia certaines sont les électeurs qui
m'ont écrit beaucoup me disant mais
pourquoi vous ne connais pas davantage
sur six revers
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que j'ai pas
pensé moi cogner sur six revers
parce que pour moi c'est pas un mauvais
bougre ouais je veux dire il s'occupait
de sa femme et s'occuper de ses filles
pour moi c'était déjà un bon point pour
qui sait quand même si rennes la sirène
c'est un type qui dit qui a dit un jour
à christine deviers-joncour dis moi la
seule chose que je sache faire c'est
donner dé porter des valises voilà ccc
distribuer des commissions voilà bien
sûr mais bien faire c'est un type il
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle les
affairistes il y en a beaucoup dans
notre république si c'est toujours
existé bien sûr même du temps de la
monarchie est là mieux vaut mieux fermer
bah oui allez bosser pour elle donc
numéro deux chez oui mais rodez est à la
traîne avait rencontré avec votre fiat
500c vous en étant dans une station et
c'est son mari qui lui a présenté corps
qui me l'a présenté donc et donc sirven
voit tout de suite la faire puisque vous
rencontrer à ce moment là sont les en
1987 vous rencontré roland dumas vous
aider roland dumas a gagné aux élections
jacques de peretti oui oui je suis de
toute façon déjà au départ de par ma
naissance et mes origines je suis plutôt
socialiste vous savez c'est le pays de
jacquou le croquant
donc j'avais bon la femme un peu surtout
la mère abandonnée
et c'est vrai que quand roland dumas est
venu se présenter en dordogne
c'est vrai que ma mère mon père l'ont
aidé dans ses campagnes s'implanter dans
la circonscription
et c'est vrai que j'ai vu un moyen bon
ça c'est donc je ne veux pas déranger je
dis je me suis dit si roland dumas
gagnent contre peretti c'est un peu ma
serre un peu de vent vous avez aidé
dumas il a gagné d'ailleurs et sirven
voyant ça se dit la bonne affaire il se
frotte les mains et il se dit je vais
envoyer christine deviers-joncour au
contact de dumas et alors là
effectivement là c'est le pactole
on peut se dire quand on lit ça qui
aurait refusé vous appelez ça n'impacte
à louis parce qu'il appelait ça la
distribution des caramels non la
distribution des carmes elle est à tout
le monde
ouais c'est pas oui mais pas que vos
pâtes mois six mois j'ai touché tuer la
bombe ainsi faire un bouton une bande
dessinée lucky luke et on a les noms et
donc sirven on peut dire vous accroche
au pognon quoi parce que c'est un peu
comme une drogue quand on en a pas
beaucoup et puis d'un coup on se
retrouve avec beaucoup d'argent c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'avec certains vont perdre un peu les
pédales sont des parce que je me
souviens au début bon moi j'avais jamais
beaucoup d'argent je vivais avec claude
jean court j'avais comme toute femme qui
vit à la maison j'étais une femme au
foyer j'avais une somme à gérer pour
mener la maison ça fait pour vous tombé
dans le circuit d'alpha tire là et c'est
je me souviens quand ils me parlaient de
somme des affaires qui brassait à droite
à gauche
je me souviens prendre un peu je prenais
un papier je rajouter les deux héros et
je refaisais 3,3 fin droit pour
comprendre parce que les paires
d'écouteurs d'anciens produits salés
pluies étaient attendues à peine à
comprendre
donc on peut dire à ce point là vous
êtes engagé chez elf alors vous aviez
onze mille francs de salaires payés en
france officiellement 40 milles qui
était payée par elf aquitaine
internationales à genève
et on peut dire un peu moins vous dites
dans votre bouquin vous a un peu vendu
votre âme au diable ce moment là oui
mais je le savais pas que je vendais mon
âme au diable
aujourd'hui communiqué les faits mais je
sais c'est un travail je faisais mon
travail et j'avais l'impression de bien
le faire je dis aujourd'hui on a noirci
même ce travail que je faisais en le
noir c'est andy mais elle a manipulé
amis
istres l'attendait quand j'essayais de
pas manipuler mais quand j'essayais de
convaincre le ministre de signer des
contrats importants pour elf aquitaine
non pas dd a signé deux contrats
importants faisant descendre le
président de la république à tel endroit
ou en négociant d'une façon bien c'était
bon pour la france plus en période de
chômage
il me le disait gf il me dit faut y
aller c'est des contrats je dirais les
avocats me dit vous allez vous auriez dû
être décoré plutôt admise à fleury
mérogis mais je crois que c'est vrai
géant pourquoi omar simon travaille
aujourd'hui pour enfoncer roland dumas
ce qu'il faut dire aussi qu'il peut dire
aussi que si effectivement c'est que
elle sape a été créée par roland dumas
ni par personne c'est des guitares de
gaulle en 58 les affaires elf aquitaine
quand on me dit aujourd'hui dans les
journaux elle l'affairé elf aquitaine de
point christine deviers-joncour attendez
moi je moi j'en peux plus là l affaire
elf aquitaine à des barres en 1958 à
l'arrivée du général de gaulle elle a
été elle a été créée par l'état pour
l'état en fait c'est une annexe ça sert
de caisse noire à l'état de gueule
depuis toujours la ferrette il faut
commencer à 1958 mais joue pas il faut
pas la faire démarrer christine les gens
attendent et on continue fait ses
parents continue l'histoire mais c'est
bien de le préciser donc là
effectivement vous avez un train de vie
l'appartement une lille
placido domingo qui vient chanter
pavarotti qui viendraient c'était bien
avant que domingo c'est déjà pas mal
un très beau pianiste ruinart soit
c'était vous et donc là c'est
effectivement vous vous êtes payés par
elle pour organiser les relations
publiques de elf donc effectivement plus
et dumas à certains à signer certains
contrats ou à s'intéresser à certaines à
certaines affaires d'ailleurs vous
faites ça très gentiment que vous dites
dans votre bukavu laisser les hommes
parlaient et vous vous êtes un petit peu
comme ça avec les fans un peu en cuisine
vous attendez que l'édile se fasse quoi
dont vous êtes vraiment au service de
cette affaire oui service mais on ne l'a
pas caché au début j'étais là pour les
aider
j'emploie yeux j'étais là aussi pour
organiser des dîners dans l'appartement
que elf mes amis à madisson robert
estienne au début c'est vrai que ce que
je faisais c'était pas deux
la république non le mal à l'heure où
nous autres faits quand on nous mettait
un contrôle des changes d'incarner
deschamps inquiet oui un carnet de
change pour traverser les frontières
ça vous choque pas avoir un compte en
suisse vous savez monsieur vous avez un
patron chez elle rentrait chez elle
moi je sais même pas ce que c'était des
cantons suisses à l'époque on vous
propose un salaire payé deux ans 1000
francs en france et on vous dit bon
c'est pas assez parce que tu travailles
beaucoup donc on va tendre vers ces a
ensuite à bout vous le refusez à la
télévision devant les caméras oui bon
alors là vous raconter d'ailleurs vous
raconter ça dans le papier de valdiguié
du parisien pour lui raconter cette
semaine là alors yaye des images
absolument extraordinaire c'est sirven
qui fait alfred sur 20 qui fait sa
tournée
alors il a une voiture et puis dans le
coffre de voiture y ait une couverture
puis sous la couverture et des billets
de billets de 500 et des liasses de
billets de 500 et il distribue quoi y
livre c'est comme le laitier sauf qu'au
lieu de livrer du lait ils vivent des
billets de 500 et alors vous ne dites
pas évidemment aujourd'hui vous n'avez
citer personne vous dit qu'il ya deux
anciens ministres
il ya un premier ministre de gauche donc
à comme on est là depuis si on
l'appliqué faut pas plus je dis dans mon
livre alfred cervin donnez donnez
toujours des trams mais ne donnait
jamais des détails trop prudent il avait
des tiroirs ils avaient des codes des
choses comme ça donc c'est un peu les
choses que je ne suis pas complètement
idiote je veux dire j'ai besoin
d'ajustement comme ça j'ai entendu des
choses je voyais bien qu'il se passait
des choses et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je je sors un peu de mes
gonds parce que parce que d'après ce que
je sais c'est que le plan des dirigeants
il ya quand même quelques quelques
semaines que mon patron est le fait
qu'elle ferait de sir20 n'ait pas été
recherchée par la justice
jusqu'à présent je dire on a mis en
prison j'ai subi tout ce que j'ai subi
et je cognais très fort donc j'apprends
ça après c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
cet acharnement de toute cette pression
médiatique sans arrêt avec l'affairé le
pressing de villoncourt l'affairé c'est
vrai que que la maintenant j'en peux
plus en plus là maintenant on prend les
et on me fait des scellés sur des gars
demeure parce que je déménage on peut
dire que mais c'est les scellés sur des
affaires de mes fils et cadeaux de
mariage non mais attendez je crois que
là c'est vrai maintenant messieurs les
chips et invisible christine c'est clair
dès que le lampiste comme on dit là
surtout vous avez quand même il ya quand
même eu dans cette affaire quatre
milliards de francs distribués à 300
personnes qui ont touché 4 milliards de
francs
alors on sait a paru dans la presse
c'est pas nous qui le dévoile ce soir
donc je veux dire ça il faut qu'on en
parle il faut que la justice fasse son
travail
il ya eu 44 6 personnes qui ont touché à
l'heureux vraiment des salaires fictifs
dans mon dossier qui sont tombés la
presse en a parlé je ne dévoile pas le
secret de l'instruction
donc cela on n'en parle plus je veux
dire cela ils n'ont pas été mis en
examen ils n'ont pas été mises en
détention pour lisa je veux dire moi ça
c'est parce que je suis une femme alors
il faut que je prenne
je vais pas je vais pas pleurer sur les
laves rire mais pas normal bien entendu
donc parallèlement à ce travail donc de
relations publiques pour elle vous
tombez enfin je pense que vous tombez
amoureux c'est pas moi dans le camp
parler mais pas aux vignes love story
etc roland dumas qui est un peu votre
pygmalion mais ça on comprend très bien
c'est un type formidable très cultivé
qui aime la vie qui a failli sera donné
d'instruction non mais c'est vrai oui
bah vous avez restauré qui est de 100
les deux sens en termes absolus dans les
deux sens
oui vous avez droit téléchargement
serait passé absolument donc ils
quittent quand même pas sa femme pour
vous mais vous connaissez beaucoup des
politiques qui titre c'est vrai que ça
fait court sachant que c'était quand
même difficile parce que j'avais jamais
connu ces milieux là j'avais 40 ans
j'avais bon les deux perles qui avait si
j'avais mes deux filles je vais dire
qu'on travaille comme ça non mais ils
avaient le bac japonais mais aujourd'hui
je me dirais mais tu as été une folle
saab était gosse et qui n'ont jamais
fait toutes les affaires le cigare c'est
pas vous
il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu un grain des
moments d'ambiguïté dans notre relation
dans votre relation avec dumas il y
avait des moments d'ambiguïté parce que
c'est vrai que bon j'étais sur mon
amoureux l'un de l'autre enfant puis des
photos dans match qu'on a vue ou qui
prouve cette relation qui parlent
d'elles-mêmes absolument vous êtes bien
être tous les deux sous et ça fait si
agréable surtout les voir sur le sable
oui et là et vous et vous vous demandez
vous demande lui me dit il vous dit de
temps en temps est ce que vous êtes là
pour moi ou pour elf aquitaine cire que
c'est quand même une relation ambiguë en
même temps parce que lui c'est bien vous
êtes vous avez accepté c'est un travail
quand même c'était c'est vrai que je
suis tombée amoureuse de ma peut-être
qu'il aurait mieux valu peut-être que ça
ne devrait pas amener leur grade
c'était plus facile en sachant et tout
le monde savait que j'étais que j'étais
la mairie de roland dumas et c'est vrai
que tout était mélangé le travail à un
moment donné tous ces croisés et c'est
vrai que roland dumas est un homme qui
comme beaucoup d'hommes
il faut quand une femme est amoureuse
selon elle s'accroche souvent elle en
veut davantage et ce genre d'homme il
faut surtout pas donc c'est vrai que moi
j'avais une chance extraordinaire et je
travaille est de plus en plus pour elf
aquitaine quand elle me disait il faut
aller le voir
merci mon dieu je pouvais aller le voir
ça c'est extraordinaire
donc ça m'a je les payais très cher tout
ça une question pas plus ce qui me gêne
en compte enfance comparaître cette
valeur c'est que vous dites enfin
j'imagine que vous l'aimiez fait que
vous dis très clairement c'est un mais
c'est en même temps c'était faire
pression de lui faire faire des choses
cette pression c'est en même temps un
peu de la manipulation aussi commander
vous arriviez dans votre cet espace
conçu leur intégrité et puis parce que
j'essaie de les incendier les choses et
c'est vrai la maîtrise et quand j'allais
le voir et que probablement peut-être il
en avait assez de me venir me voir en
tant que elf aquitaine
peut-être qu'il avait envie de dire que
je vienne le voir en tant que christine
vous aurez vie vraiment et j'arrivais en
tant qu elle s'est souvent est basé sont
félicités tout parce que je trouve qui
fait la différence entre le passé et le
présent c'est contre c'est que les
hommes sont devenus vachement plus lâche
beaucoup plus avant les rois il afficher
leurs maîtresses et assumer leur bâtard
et aujourd'hui il couche avec
en dehors du mariage réussi à assumer
stéphane piscine est l'exemple même des
rangs dit toujours dans l' affaire elf
dans la sphère elle le sol est toujours
dans la sphère est le seul bonhomme sait
que s'il vient les gens et on m'a dit ça
récemment mais c'est vrai mais qui
paraît qu'il y avait un homme dont elle
s'acquitte n c'était moi c'est bien de
choses sur lesquelles on s'est focalisé
rien selon lesquelles la presse s'est
focalisée il ya effectivement vous ayez
aussi l'histoire des chaussures oui
enfin de super de chaussures à onze
mille francs oui c'est vrai que ça
impressionne les gens une paire de
chaussures à onze mille francs marché
avec un smic à chaque pied c'est un
énorme buzz qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mes jambes d'abord ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'on n'est pas une infirmité
c'est vrai que ce sont des chaussures
cher mais c'est vrai que soient pas de
la simple coquetterie
non mais là c'est vrai du coup je me dis
pas du tout parce que tout le monde me
demande c'est vrai que roland dumas a
mais peut-être qu'il n'aimerait pas que
je dis ça c'est vrai qu'il a un problème
et il a fait une chute de ski à 30 ans
il n'a pas voulu faire opérer et là un
tibia qui s'est soudée comme ça voilà
manque 5 cm et au fil des années sa et
claudie comme talleyrand et ils
souffrent et moi je me souviens qu'à
l'époque est à dire la comparaison c'est
juste pour ça non mais j'ai plein de
copains venus faire une paire de
chaussures parce qu'elle voulait lui
faire plaisir parce qu'il y avait des
gens plus combien on pas les faire
plaisir je lui ai dit il faut que vous
alliez vous faire faire des chaussures
alors en bas de chez moi il
il faisait des chaussures sur mesure et
qui a pu lui mettre faire un une fauche
pas une forme mon problème les élus
faire exactement le ce qui manquait pour
qui et qui ne souffre plus voilà et l'aï
l'avs commander ses chaussures
et le jour où il a fallu aller les
chercher en partie partait en voyage
j'accompagnais le voyage officiel les
socrates et le secrétariat m'appelle
dire le ministre des ses chaussures il
avait des stations debout à faire et
les voeux je passe était en bas mais
voilà et oui mais depuis quand on parle
du président conseil du conseil
constitutionnel ou dit roland dumas et
ses pairs il rappelé bon on continue
alors donc après je vais vite affaire
des frégates parce que ça on n'est pas
là pour raconter la sphère des frégates
vendues à taïwan
vous touchez finalement bon et qui est
ce qu'elles ont été vendus grâce à vous
pas grâce à vous on va pas faire ça il y
avait à l'époque effectivement par
françoise sagan par exemple à et c'est
que ces publics a influé sur le
président mitterrand à l'époque où on
avait trouvé du pétrole en ouzbékistan
quand on est près des gens puissants
tout le monde essaye de les faire
changer d'avis et même sur écoute
miletic il entend du centre
dépressionnaire l'action alors décrit
dans quelques années on saura ce qu'est
l'avortement et livrer les lignes
françaises
mais alors rien dites donc vous toucher
45 millions
vous dites pas nous en donner un peu les
a rendus vous avez rendu 6 puis voilà
vous dites je les ai rendu et
l'appartement de la rue de lille je suis
parti vous êtes partis veulent donc
voilà aujourd'hui vous vous retrouvez
ses cris voilà un deuxième roman un
premier roman versé une caution de 1
million de familles au revoir sentir
prison comment on va pouvoir sortir de
prison je suis sorti de prison et on m'a
tout ne m'ont donné un mois près de moi
prendre à repousser à trois mois et le
10 septembre il fallait que je verse 1
million
subban y retourner c'est vrai que
j'avais pas les sous la course contre la
montre alors j'ai écrit ce livre pour
cette raison aussi en même temps pour
pour dire qu'ils jettent et parce que
les médias m'avait tellement massacrés
et que c'était pas possible de survivre
à ça j'ai bien fait de faire le lit va
sûrement connaître jeu et c'est vrai
qu'au départ j'ai écrit ce livre d'abord
pour ça mais après bon c'est vrai que ça
m'a servi à payer la caution
et puis et puis
les anciens copains ils vous aident la
manoeuvre est dans le pétrin ne soit due
to a du talent a dû être en prison de
gens qui datait des lettres anonymes où
elle reconnaissait des détails qui
prouvait que c'était ses amis d'avant
qu'il a balancé sur la nature humaine
c'est une leçon formidable dans des
lettres anonymes qui sont tombés dans
mon dossier j'ai retrouvé des phrases et
je savais exactement qui pouvait dire ça
des intimes on avance alors donc vous
allez en prison là effectivement vous
passez directement c'est vrai que c'est
c'est la roche tarpéienne est proche du
capitole parce que c'est vrai que vous
passez de la rue de lille de ce luxe
effectivement à la prison c'est terrible
quoi vous raconter je peux pas le faire
ici parce qu'on n'est pas là pour faire
mireille dumas justement mais vous voilà
à quoi vous raconter c'est vrai que
c'est on va essayer de vous on a essayé
de vous casser pour faire parler pour
vous citiez les avocats ont dénoncé un
chantage médiatique chantage chez nous
la cédons chantage judiciaire pour me
faire parler mes avocats m'ont dit que
si j'avais dit des choses sur dumas
genève est comprise a entendu et donc
vous résister alors vous vous votre
tension tombe à 6 vous perdez 12 kg on
met votre fils en garde à vue vous
résister à toutes ces humiliations de la
prison ces gens là lumière allumée
les gens qui vous regardent par
l'oeilleton enfin je vais pas vous le
racontez vous enlevez votre sourire bien
tenu vous êtes mieux quand vous soyez
comme moi voilà non mais bon ça c'est
dans le bouquin disons que c'est très
pénible à lire et que ça a dû être
effectivement encore beaucoup plus peiné
la détention toute façon qu'elles soient
provisoires ou pas provisoire c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'en sortant je m'étais
dit je vais me battre pour ça pour que
ça se sache
un pays des droits de l'homme qu'est la
france qui se targue d'être champion
qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut c'est
honteux de laisser mange pas je peux pas
la situation je suis me battre mais
peut-être un jour je le ferai si je peux
jamais les moyens
si vous avez peur en prison c'est
l'argent il ya deux types qui viennent
on vous dit à deux types qui sont
passées vous dire c'est qu'ils les types
qui sont vraiment durs pas à nouveau la
porte pour donner la gamelle et il ya la
madone et puis une co détenus qui sert
et et
c'est tout et là je vois deux messieurs
habillé comme vous dans son look sans la
cravate là mais un peu comme ça et
publiés normalement oui et puis ils ont
regardé comme ça dans la cellule j'ai
trouvé ça très étrange et come back au
cellulaire plus l'habitude de la prison
que moi elle a été tout de suite très
très inquiète elle m'a dit ça c'est
dangereux
alors on s'est renseigné effectivement
en nous à moi j'ai mis ma petite enquête
les la prison m'a dit que c'était des
gens qui étaient venus faire le devis
d'une cuisine delà des cuisines de
fleury et en fait on a appris après que
la cuisine était en fait depuis deux ans
je sais pas qui sont vraiment pour
rénover les noms mais toute façon c'est
clair aujourd'hui vous savez beaucoup de
choses ce qui vous poseraient pas
beaucoup de choix je le dis dans mon
livre alfred cervin donner des trams ne
donnez jamais les détails ce que je dis
dans le parisien aujourd'hui je peux pas
en dire davantage je veux dire j'ai pas
j'ai pas allé non j'ai pas assisté moi
de toute façon le fait vous pouvez je
sais que ça existe mais d'être médiatisé
vous protège d'une certaine façon je
crois que oui pour une question très
belle très pragmatique 16 mois comment
vous vivez ça parce que je le vis très
mal
ouais je le vis je suis là il faut que
je me batte il faut que j'aille jusqu'au
bout j'ai mes fils qui comptent sur moi
et sinon je serais pas ressorti que le
riz mérogis ouais vous et pensez vous
suicider la ba oui plusieurs fois vous
êtes un peu dans la situation de marilyn
monroe
j'avais tellement de choses que les
kennedy l'ont fait supprimer vous savez
ce qui est terrible c'est pas ton la
détention la détention c'est une horreur
mais ce qui est le plus dur je crois
c'est que vous savez on allait être en à
la télé on comptines et jeux on avait la
télé dans la cellule c'est de se voir un
beau jour christine deviers-joncour
comme ça en haut un et vous prenez ça de
plein fouet dans huit mètres carrés
assis sur votre page
mais c'est pas vrai en fait c'était mon
image qu'on avait filé en mille morceaux
en reprenait ses morceaux comme un peu
et on mettait et je me reconnaissais pas
je crois que la pression médiatique en
prison m'a fait encore plus de mal que
la justice ou la détention
vous voyez ça cet été les parce que vous
êtes là vous pouvez pas parler pour rien
dire que vous connais qu'entre les murs
ce qu'on appelle la charge oui mais en
prison oui il s'agit bien sûr des rares
on peut aller parler d'une prison c'est
une horreur on peut rien faire puisque
vous énerver ses comprenait des vieux
bouts de films j ai pas gens avec ce que
c'est parce que j'avais l'heure de
vérité avec quoi avec mes lunettes
noires et j'avais l'impression d'être
sais pas à quoi c'est effrayant voyez
comment votre avenir là moi je vois pas
d'avenir manger gère au jour le jour
mais pour l'instant j'ai pas d'avenir
vous savez j'ai j'ai plus de liberté
vous savez je suis j'ai le droit de
sortir de ce contrôle n'est pas le plein
de gens que je dois pas voir jeu bon
c'est vrai que je suis très encadrée
donc j'ai pas beaucoup de liberté
j'en ai une c'est que le jour où j'en
peux plus j'arrête c'est tout c'est la
seule que j'ai et j'en ai une deuxième
c'est à travers un roman que je suis en
train d'écrire mais qui est un roman qui
est une fiction je vais pouvoir parler
un petit peu de choses de caractère des
gens de ça c'est une liberté parce que
là c'est vrai que là c'était christine
deviers joncour oui mais là j'ai envie
de parler des trains plus pleins et les
hommes d'ajustement je vais parler des
hommes donc merci en tous les cas de
votre franchise et bravo pour votre
courage
on continue sur le lynchage médiatique
sur les victimes des médias de cuisine
vous restez avec nous volontiers on vous
garde et on accueille djamel bouras et
francis lalanne
[Musique]
djamel bouras bonsoir alors vous aurez
l'occasion dans le mur qui viennent
d'expliquer ce qu'on vient si vous êtes
champion du monde de judo olympique
champion olympique de judo
oui du coup il confond avec la boxe
n'est pas très grave si bien et on va
voir donc l'histoire vous allez nous
raconter l'histoire qui vous est arrivé
francis lalanne bonsoir
et gérard millière
otez moi d'un doute c'est le gérard
muller de france inter c'est le gérard
miller qui est tous les jours et coûter
par deux millions deux cent cinquante
mille personnes dans tous les sens où et
qui est victime des médias
il est pas victime des médias mais il a
un avis sur les médias l'un a dit
surtout gérard muller non mais je vous
écoute tous les jours mes parents vous
trouve mes chances parce des pâtes
méchant non
bon d'accord alors on va commencer avec
vous francis lalanne d'abord votre
actualité
moi je ne suis pas une victime des
médias vous n'êtes pas une victime des
médias vous avez quand même et je suis
pas là pour ça je suis là pour parler de
la sortie de mon livre et de mon
spectacle au bataclan mais on va en
parler en masse le 12 février
on va là on va commencer dans l'embardée
donc je tiens à dire que en ce qui me
concerne je n'ai je n'ai accusé ni
personne d'aucun crime concernant wii
puisque pour moi le monde médiatique est
un monde qui s'exprime et on connaît
sont engagées que partir du moment où on
connaît son langage on accepte ou alors
qu'on ne fait pas ce métier vous voulez
plutôt refusé parce que vous avez quand
même moi clairement oui oui c'est ouvert
on peut dire quand même que vous êtes
quelqu'un qui a toujours eu maille à
partir avec jacques en boxer pas mal
vous c'est pas le judo c'est la boxe
vous avez beaucoup c'est quand même pas
mal de photographes hamad le journal y
faisait toujours été un peu rebelle par
rapport au système médiatique et vous
l'ont fait payer de personne ne m'a rien
fait payer et je n'ai boxé personne
contrairement à ce qu'on peut lire dans
la presse mais pardon tous les articles
qui sont dans vos dossiers de presse et
qui concerne les bagarres vous avec des
reporteurs avec des joints de chasser
faut écouter la façon dont l'histoire
est racontée et bien entendu fossat et
je viens de raconter la vraie alors je
pense pas non moi je pense que vous avez
vérifié vous parce qu'il n'a peut-être
jamais depuis que ces personnes n'aient
pas commencé ce soir je veux dire c'est
que un jour là jean cocteau a dit je
suis un mensonge qui dit toujours la
vérité
je crois que c'est un petit peu une
phrase qu'on pourrait appliquer au monde
médiatique le monde médiatique n'est
plus là pour informer les là pour
distraire on le sait est hélas on va y
suit les tendances qu'ils pensent être
celle des autres ça dit du spectateur et
qui souvent ne le sont pas d'ailleurs
et quand on pense que les gens ont
besoin de potins on leur sort du potin
quand on pense que les gens ont besoin
des missions culturelles on leur serre
octane en fait les gens ont besoin des
choses très saine mais comme ils sont
très fatigués quand ils rentrent du
travail
il regarde ce qu'on leur montre à la
télé et puis in fine ce qui à manger
alors ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
fait sept ans par exemple qu'on vous a
pas vu on peut pas dire qu'on leur
montre souvent francis lalanne moi j'ai
dû faire à peu près une dizaine d'une
quinzaine de télévision en 20 ans c'est
un choix personnel
j'ai eu la chance d'arriver dans ce
métier à une époque où le monde
médiatique n'avait pas autant
d'importance et les gens sortaient de
chez eux ils allés à la rencontre des
artistes est un petit peu ce qui est en
train de se passer maintenant grâce à
l'avènement du du rap du tout les
groupes alternatifs qui se produisent
dans des lieux non non subventionnées
enfin non je vais décider d'être
marginal en quelque sorte que ça se
passait mal un génial par rapport à quoi
et par rapport à qui bas par rapport aux
médias mais à l'heure était alors moi tu
l'aies on s'est rencontré il ya 15 ans
dans une émission sur tf1 actionnaire et
scoop à la une je m'en souviens très
bien ma vie ces deux phrases génial m'a
dit quand vous étiez sur scène et que ça
se passait très bien vous jouissiez dans
votre votre j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que
j'ai il m'était arrivé de ressentir un
plaisir extrême avant d'en regardera la
bande s'est assurée si vous pouviez
arrêté mais je veux dire c'est qu'on
avait retenu que ça de francis larger
pas retenu que ça s'agite ça dénote un
certain état d'esprit vous viendrez que
ça mais je suis on est là moi je vais
revenir aujourd'hui l'armée les chars
venus une fois dans double jeu non ce
que je veux dire simplement c'est que
vous avez été mis à l'écart des par les
gens des médias atteint personnes à bord
alors parlons de vos spectacles vous
faites une comédie musicale avec herbert
pagani au bataclan qui s'appelle
megalopolis ouais bah parlons-en c'est
quoi eh bien puisque je suis venu pour
ça je vais donc en parler cher cher
thierry il s'agit donc d'un spectacle
une comédie musicale
dans ma très jeune carrière puisqu'elle
n'a que 20 ans je n'avais encore jamais
participé à une comédie musicale et elle
a été mise en scène est adapté de
l'oeuvre d'herbert pagani par un jeune
metteur en scène qui s'appelle bernard
bittan dont j'avais vu un spectacle il
ya quelques années qui m'avait
bouleversé qui s'appelait le sel et le
miel et donc il a adapté l'oeuvre de
pagani la trouver dans les chansons de
pagani des personnages ce qui est
extraordinaire ça raconte quoi alors
megalopolis à raconte une histoire très
contemporaine et qui va vous plaire je
pense thierry vous qui êtes un
publiciste c'est-à-dire un polémiste et
non pas quelqu'un qui fait la publicité
ça raconte l'histoire d'un monde
consensuel qui s'enferre dans le dans
les haras dans l'es2 le marasme de la
pensée unique c'est à dire vous savez on
n'est plus dans un monde totalitaire
aujourd'hui où là le pouvoir s'exerce
par la violence armée
on est dans un monde subliminal où la
violence s'exerce par une dialectique
très simple qui est celle de
l'alternance de la caresse avec une
manipulation médiatique qui tend à
culpabiliser celui qui ne pense pas la
même chose que la majorité n'avait pas
souvent à la télé mais quand vous venez
à damas après sont infinies non mais
c'est très bien le seul mot que je veux
dire si vous permettez cham ag sont
pressés que l'expression de cette vie
intime c'est à dire de la relation
amoureuse qui pratiquent entre eux ou de
la relation d'amitié qui patine pratique
entre eux et bien s'est présenté comme
étant finalement aujourd'hui la réponse
au pouvoir vertical je crois que plus
aux villes intime plus envie d'amitié
plus envie d'amour personnel et plus on
y rebelles voilà ce que raconte cet
israélien
gérard miller ça vous branche pas les
voir cette pièce
jonathan non semaines et demie si je
réponds oui
non non non les dire non non je trouve
que vous l'avez bien présentés mais je
vous en remerçie vrai bien présent on a
le droit de ne pas adhérer
moi je suis tellement pour la liberté
d'expression que même pour le droit à
l'injure oui oui je préfère qu'un
journaliste 10-15 mensonge et qui
n'arrête pas de dire une vérité je vais
pas justifier ce que je vais dire
maintenant parce que je connais bien la
lan d'abord parce que j'étais ado
j'allais voir quand il chantait sous les
chapiteaux à l'époque
et puis ils étaient très bons comédiens
aussi dans l'affrontement avec
jean-pierre mais bon évidemment il a des
défauts on les connaît les défauts
d'alan il s'emporte facilement est un
peu parfois je garde mon calme vous avez
pu avec c'est vrai je vous connais bien
vous emportez un peu facilement est-ce
que c'est pas un peu de la provoc quand
même d'appeler ça megalopolis dégâts
d'eau avec la ligne d'écouté
moi j'ai déjà écrit tous les articles
mégalo francis était un machin ou bon
est ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
pas moi qui écris le titre et
megalopolis on va faire un peu
d'étymologie un peu de grecs police et
la ville mégalo vous connaissez c'est la
grande ville c'est un hasard bon et de
toute façon le regard des autres
n'engage que qu'eux-mêmes et le regard
des autres moi n'allons pas vous savez
que vous allez au-devant des critiques
avec ce titre là et elle a l'habitude
non mais écoutez on quand on fait ce
métier on va au devant des critiques
mais on va au devant de joie qui sont
bien plus immense que les petits des
plaisirs que peuvent nous causer la
presse
je vais passer souvent à côté du théâtre
où francis lalanne jouer l'affrontement
c'est quelqu'un qui va au devant des
choses c'est important c'est quelqu'un
qui écoute et s'éclairer qui alors je
sais pas comment la pièce s'appelle
l'affrontement moi j'ai jamais vu a fait
commencer pas le flatter parce qu'à vous
clamez berne
comment s'est passée pas un prince et
bras droit sujet un verbe un compliment
est ce que devient alors celui qui a
calé riyad ou idéal épigrammes amoureuse
et vous dites que il faut lire une page
juste avant de faire l'amour à chaque
fois oui enfin je sers besoin de passer
voir quand même jour sa naturelle ça y
est c'est agaçant poèmes non mais c'est
un conseil moi je pense que l'amour
l'amour charnel l'amour charnel a aussi
besoin de mots et je pense que les
poètes c'est leur rôle de donner des
maux au plaisir oui alors ça les ponts
avec journée bien sûr et puis depuis 200
ans vous étiez où j'ai fait bien des
choses la lame mon interruption de la
baisse d'activité de deux chanteurs est
dû avant tout au fait que j'ai eu un
procès avec une maison de disques dont
kim a interdit pendant des années
puisqu'il a duré sept ans cinq ans
exactement m'interdit de d'enregistrer
et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai pas pu le
faire donc j'ai développé d'autres
choses j'ai développé la littérature
j'ai publié des livres de poèmes j'en ai
j'en ai évité d'autres j'ai développé la
dramatique puisque j'ai joué pendant
trois ans avec jean piat de saison à
paris puis une tournée en province
et puis j'ai gagné mon procès est donc
maintenant ça me permet de pouvoir
prétendre à enregistrer un nouvel album
ce que je suis en train de faire en
français pour moi en espagnol aussi pour
une tournée que je vais faire en
amérique du sud et j'enregistre
également l'album du spectacle
megalopolis qui sera versé en trois
albums donc gérer un drap pour vous qui
vous êtes occupé des petites figurines
aussi alors j'ai également pendant cette
période
relancer une entreprise dans le périgord
qu une région que de vous devez
connaître la cuisine devient connais
bien quitte l'entreprise
pas encore et ils n'ont pas encore
trouvé chaussure à leur pied
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que non
non je suis beaucoup de respect pour
roland dumas je voulais dire voilà et
simplement non ce sont des c'est une
entreprise qui votre côté asocial sa
part dont cirque cambodgien
non c'est le pass anneau christine
jamais d'accord là dessus quand roland
dumas dit le présent la public peut plus
être attaquée est vraiment aux miracles
peut pas être embêté sur les hlm de
paris
et quand roland dumas pour paraître
emmerder sur el fida chirac la
possibilité de ne pas être attaqué sur
les la mairie de paris les hlm de paris
vous n'allez pas me dire qu'enfin
franchement c puis je vous rira bien un
type comme vous un type honnête comme
vous alors puisse vous répondre répondez
moi parce que je serais curieux de
connaître votre réponse là dessus j'ai
vu le dessin du monde lui serre la main
chirac et du match disons merci et tous
que c'est la plus belle une du monde que
j'ai vu depuis longtemps tout et moi je
vais vous dire une chose je n'ai jamais
été en accord avec les thèses du
gouvernement que défendent et roland
dumas
je les ai combattu j'ai payé le prix
pour ça mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je crois que l'on peut combattre
quelqu'un en tout cas combattre les
idées de quelqu'un et le respecter bon
alors mis leur faisait quelque chose à
quelqu'un dire publiquement qu'il a de
la sympathie pour roland dumas moi j'en
ai aussi beaucoup
je suis cependant d'accord avec vous sur
le conseil constitutionnel je trouve que
ça peut vraiment un problème de
soupçonner à ce point les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel mais juste la
question roland dumas c'est formidable
quand même dans un pays comme le nôtre à
quel point un moment donné on a le
sentiment qu'on ne peut plus dire du
bien de quelqu'un pour ils ont
immédiatement être soupçonnée du pire
je suis absolument pour cette enquête a
jusqu'au bout et d'un autre côté c'est
vrai que je trouve formidable qu'on
puisse dire qu'on a versé un bâtiment
roland dumas parce que c'est un type
formidable
s'il a fait des choses que la loi
réprouve et bien qu'il soit puni mais
c'est quand même bien que c'est
quelqu'un qui passe même pas si souvent
que ça dans les médias lalanne parce que
dans l'ensemble à l'acheter c'est quand
même un moment donné de se dire oh de
toute façon je vais pas me compromettre
tout le monde table ce roland dumas je
vais faire pareil très bien ses vues
c'est dit merci djamel bouras alors nous
avait déclaré
l'histoire qui même histoire qui m'est
arrivé c'est une cycliste djamel bourras
le cycliste est jeune elle brasse vous
avez déclaré c'est une histoire à la
omar m'a tuer ce qui m'est arrivé alors
raconté nouveau brièvement comment vous
avez l'histoire comment vous l'avez vécu
dix ans très bien oui apparemment vous
avez un beau sourire bien sûr
malheureusement wes comme a toujours
appris que l'essentiel cette boire de
manger de respirer mais meehan omar m'a
tuer parce que j'ai suivi la dernière
fois son son histoire et c'est vraiment
en plus quand j'expliquais un peu ça
c'est comme si comme accusé d'un meurtre
ils ont aujourd'hui que je me retrouve
en inde ou ouais c'est vraiment et c'est
ça le pire c'est cool c'est d'un côté
heureusement qu'on a les médias mais à
cause des médias
les gens qui savent que je suis innocent
n'ont pas voulu m'innocenter ce qu'ils
auraient perdu de la crédibilité
oui il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas utilisée
aussi c'est la mentalité c'est ça c'est
que en france une drôle de mentalité et
quand je parle de la france il faut pas
dire oui tu es français oui je suis fier
d'être français je suis français mais on
est on est de mauvaise mentalité là ya
des ministres qui est arrivé et qui veut
faire parler d'elle je trouve attendait
de moi ça va finir parce que je sais
parler beaucoup suite à la non cet avis
de faire parce que c'est si je dis ça
c'est que c'est bien lui et autres
dessins bien sûr je suis un des premiers
à lutter contre le dopage contre le
sport mais il ya une façon de le faire
c'est à dire arriver en france
essayer de casser des cyclistes sachant
que là vous expliquer par pour la
mentalité c'est que dans le cyclisme
tous les français le savent que ça se
passe comme ça
les partenaires le savent le monde
entier le tout d'un coup soit disant on
sort un gros comme ça en voulant casser
tout le monde pourquoi en ce moment mais
dire que sans dopage en prépa le tour de
france en vingt jours je sais pas
comment des faits nous devions sur les
juges
mais si on s'est moqué devient il faut
pas être faux cul parce qu'on sait tous
moquette vire à gauche il faut arrêter
aussi sauf moi nous serions serait moqué
c'est aussi parce que je dois vite vous
même
en tout le monde sait que tous les
coureurs sont dopés lors pourquoi l'ue
est bloquée vous de ce qu'il faut au
départ tous les autres
j'ai rien à dire non mais là c'est là où
il a fait une connerie mais non mais
quand il a fait sa connerie lui la saq
lui tombe sur la tête
donc c'est difficile de quoi moi si
j'avais été à sa place je pense j'en
sais rien moi je l'aurais tous dénoncé
je m'en fous moi moi je dénonce poudre
mais c'est ça le truc mais que que lui
est-il alors la plus isolée
il a pas eu cette force où je sais pas
il était mal conseillé si on apporte de
la mort du pet haut ses couleurs que
vous appelez mètres gp c'est vraiment ça
on avait l'impression il a répondu m
pourvu jeu on avait l'impression d'un
garçon qui était une marionnette avec un
avocat qui lui disait faut dire ça ça
passage il a misé sur la mauvaise
graisse maison vachement abusé trop trop
c'est trop il faut savoir s'excuser je
pense qu'ils ont été trop loin
[Musique]